Paul who is a Jew so he's not
anti-semitic just told you the covenant
made on Sinai which is Jerusalem on
earth that is
now typified represented symbolized in
Hagar because Hagar is the Bond woman
who gave birth to a son who was in
bondage and these Jews if they're trying
to now Merit righteousness before God by
keeping the Mosaic law they will be in
bondage to sin and they will come under
God's Wrath so understand the point
Earthly Jerusalem after rejecting Jesus
is no longer the Jerusalem of God then
what is the Jerusalem of God well read
continue okay what is the Jerusalem that
Delights God that pleases God which
Sarah
represents okay keep reading
but the Jerusalem that above is free and
she is our mother for what's your mother
the the free Jerusalem and where's that
at I don't think it's an actual place no
it is it's Heavenly Jerusalem okay where
you got to know your Bible it's Hebrews
12:22 to 24 and Revelation 21 says and I
saw Jerusalem coming down out of heaven
like a bride adorned for her
husband okay that's got know your Bible
so which Jerusalem is the Jerusalem that
Delights the heart of God the heavenly
Jerusalem in Hebrews and Revelation and
go to Hebrews 12:22 to 24 to show you
that the real Jerusalem is the one in
heaven and it's coming down at the end
of the age when the Lord returns Hebrews
12 22- 24 so you don't think I'm making
it up Hebrews 12:22 to
okay but you have come to mount Zion to
the city of the Living God the heavenly
Jerusalem the what the Heavenly
Jerusalem so there's a Zion in
heaven I guess so don't guess come on
sister don't guess according to this yes
so there's a Zion in
heaven yes and that's the city of the
Living God yes Heavenly Jerusalem yes
you have come to thousands upon
thousands of angels and joy assembly to
the Church of the firstborn whose names
are written in heaven you have come to
God the judge of all to the spirits of
the righteous made perfect to Jesus the
mediator of a New Covenant and to the
sprinkled blood that speaks a better
word than the blood of Abel so in
Heavenly Jerusalem that's the city of
God yes and in that city of God you have
Zion and
Jerusalem yes and who lives there God
the Father who lives there Jesus Christ
who lives there myriads of angels who
lives there the spirits of those who
died in Christ who are now perfected
because their bodies are in the dust
their Spirits are there and what are
they having there they're having
church because there's Church there
right right so which is the true
Jerusalem that God Delights in
the Heavenly Jerusalem exactly because
remember what Jesus said when the Jews
rejected him the kingdom would take be
taken away from them and the city and
the temple were destroyed as a sign that
God was done with them I'm going to show
you that but I want you to go slow with
me so you caught it right right now go
to Revelation 21 to see it is the
Heavenly Jerusalem that is the real
Jerusalem and Sarah symbolizes the
Heavenly Jerusalem and we who belong to
Christ belong to Heavenly Jerusalem
those who reject CH Christ belong to
Earthly Jerusalem which Hagar
represents okay go to Revelation 21
veres 1 and two then I saw a new Heaven
and a new Earth for the first Heaven and
the first Earth had passed away and
there was no longer any
sea I saw the holy city the New
Jerusalem coming down out of Heaven from
God prepared as a bride beautifully
dressed for her husband and when that
Heavenly Jerusalem comes down Guess
who's coming down with it now read three
and four
okay we can open up the entire chapter I
should have just had you open the entire
chapter sorry my fault okay and I heard
a loud voice from the throne saying look
God's dwelling place is now among the
people and He will dwell oh wait did you
catch it when does God dwell with
mankind when Heavenly Jerusalem comes
down because that's the city of God
where God dwells in right
yes so when that Jerusalem comes down
that means god is coming down to dwell
with us in the new heaven new Earth so
look God's Dwelling Places with men now
keep reading all the way to four they
will be his people and God himself will
be with them and be their God he will
wipe every tear from their eyes there
will be no more death or Mourning or
crying or pain for the old Order of
Things has passed
away okay now I'm going to show you now
who the true Jews the true Israel the
true people of God happen to be slowly
but you're following this pattern so now
go to Galatians 3
26-29 Galatians 326 but open up the
entire chapter because I'm going to show
you something so open up Galatians 3 the
entire chapter you're reading the NIV
right uh yes the new Indian version or
nearly inspired version which is it
Anyway NIV takes a lot of Liberties but
that's okay go to Galatians chapter 3
okay now I want want you to see who the
true offspring of Abraham is are you
ready yes read Galatians 31
15-18 3:15 to18 brothers and sisters let
me take an example from everyday life
just as no one can set aside or add to a
human Covenant that has been duly
established so it is in this case the
promises were spoken to Abraham and to
his seed scripture say and to seeds
meaning many people but scripture does
not say it says scripture does not say
and to seeds many people but to
seed okay right because you miss the way
you read it I heard you saying scripture
says and to seeds okay oh does not say
and to seeds yeah now read it meaning
many people but and to your seed meaning
one person who is Christ so who's the
true Seed of
Abraham Christ he is the seed right yes
the one person Christ he is the seed
right yes the one seed yes all right now
go to Galatians 3: 26-29 now watch this
Galatians 3
2629 so in Christ Jesus you are all
children of God through faith for all of
you who were baptized into Christ have
clothed yourselves with Christ there is
neither Jew nor Gentile neither slave
nor free wait there's no longer Jew nor
Gentile yes wead that again there is
neither Jew nor Gentile neither slave
nor free nor is there male and female
for you are all in one Christ Jesus for
you are all one in Christ
Jesus all one in Christ Jesus and then
what are you if you're in Christ what
are you
29 if you belong to Christ then you are
Abraham's seed and HS according to the
promise wait sister the Seed of Abraham
are believers in Jesus who are baptized
into
Jesus yes so a gentile who believes in
Jesus and is baptized in Jesus he is the
son she is the daughter of Abraham the
Seed of
Abraham yes so why are you making a big
deal over the state of
Israel and taking their side over
against Palestine you don't take
anyone's side you just read from a Jew
those who are baptized in
Christ ethnically Jewish or a gentile or
a male or a female you're all one and
you are the Seed of Abraham Abraham is
all of your father he's the father of
all of
you this is a lot you have to understand
and I know it's a lot because you've
been indoctrinated like I was but what
I'm trying to get at is if you believe
your Bible and you let Jesus tell you
what to believe and the holy spirit
filled Apostles and the New Testament
writers Paul wrote that he's a Jew I
didn't write it I didn't write Galatians
3 and in Galatians 3 he told you there's
neither Jew nor Gentile Greek neither
male nor female neither free nor slave
you are all all one if you've been
baptized in Christ and all of you are
the Seed of Abraham well if Netanyahu
rejects Jesus then according to Paul
he's not a real Jew but that Palestinian
in Palestine who's been baptized in
Christ he is a real Jew so when a drop
don't tell me God is fighting for
Israel don't tell me that